what is going on reject nation we're
gonna watch
brooklyn nine nine today and i'm walking
is a one episode eh
yeah hot dog very excited for this guys
brooklyn nine-nine is a gem
was in line last week when it comes to
these temporary
blocks but always a crappier right now
at the time of filming this
episode 5 and episode 7 are currently
the ones that are blocked with
60 of our audience those will eventually
become
unblocked every one of these has been
temporarily blocked a few days after
uploading it's weird i'm not going into
a product placement thingy right now
i'm just telling you guys all right
that's the situation updating you guys
so that's why i really do appreciate
everyone who has been following us over
at our patreon
because this stuff really affects us
please go ahead
hit that like button and subscribe click
that notification bell and yes full
length watch long as we'll write our
patreon and we cover many shows with the
same tier you get the option for
reaction highlights and watch alongs at
the same tier thank you to everyone
who's been following us and oh yeah
thanks to predom janelle for editing
these for us buddy
[Music]
the cinch is too much we got to get
those shoes out of here how much time do
we have
scullyard has pop by 30 minutes ago so
we probably got 10 minutes left on this
nap
12 if he's turkey tired tryptophan ah
it's trapped abort mission i have an
[Laughter]
idea
[Laughter]
oh wait yeah it just smells worse than
before oh
guys guys you gotta think this through
you gotta think this through poor scully
i would love to try
out one of those rovers and try on one
of those suits although i think the
rover
would be way more fun whoa why are you
here before me
am i asleep is this a dream i am early
because
jimmy brogan is here today why do you
care so much about some old reporter
stacy keach jimmy brogan wrote the squad
about badass new york cops in the 70s
it's the best book i've ever read
and i've read 15 books 50 books is not a
lot
wait you said 15. rogan i am a huge fan
of your book
would you mind signing my copy i'd love
to it's always nice to meet a fan
those new york cops from the 70s you
wrote about were my idols i mean
gaminsky kavanaugh quigg those guys were
the real deal
i once saw gaminsky choke a hippie to
death with his own ponytail
he'll be observing the two of you on
your internet identity theft case
how do logan's presence doesn't prove to
be a distraction to you
it's gonna be smooth sailing today we're
going to work on our courtroom demeanor
pass you're testifying in an aggravated
assault case tomorrow why
i'm fine on the stand look i'll make
this real simple so even these dum-dums
can understand
man did crime
i love her this is an important case
you need to do well fine i'll take your
dumbass seminar
oh good god why do you smell like an
ashtray oh sorry
mom it's the only way i can cope with
the stress of the job
stupid well you could think of the
algorithm as a boot
and the ip address is some poor slob
skull you know
we used to call guys who bragged about
sitting around all day
hair bags except for detective finale
no he had to sit around all day a mafia
thug pried both his kneecaps off with a
crowbar
so lucky
[Laughter]
do me a favor wake me when your shift is
over no way
that is amazing
if they like you they'll trust you fine
how do i get these morons to like me
don't call them morons good instinct
hey don't be afraid to smile and always
make good eye contact
but don't stare at people yeah you got
to blink but don't playing too much
or too fast i think the bigger worry
slow blinks don't blink
please can i jump onto a sweet mob
related homicide there are no sweet mob
related conversations on which to die
why do you idolize that man and the time
he wrote about because the 70s were
amazing i mean everyone had thick juicy
mustaches and all the clothes were
orange and flammable
santiago never would have made detective
and an openly gay man like me i never
would have been given a command
there were very few black detectives did
i ever tell you what my first day on the
job was like
hello i'm raymond holt are you here to
turn yourself in
oh god
they were great detectives some of them
were legit some of them were just
brogan's drinking buddies
sir that is a brilliant idea it wasn't
an idea it was a scathing indictment of
your personal hero
yeah 601. one time during a drug bust he
had one of his fingers shot off
he didn't even flinch he just picked it
up and used it to flip off every puerto
rican in the place
oh my god
how about another round are you kidding
me i want to hang with you until one of
us dies
there you go all right
uh oh it's ty
pretty hungover turn off your mouth
siren
here are the texts i got from you last
night best night ever
why scotch burns so good picture of you
on the subway platform eating chinese
chicken salad with no shirt on
we had an epic night of bonding that i
will never forget
do it i believe in you oh no
throw it i believe in you
man i wonder if brogan's okay he's 65
and drink two bottles of scotch he might
be dead
morning kid how you doing oh hey
oh no people
might say that all the black leather
kind of makes you look like an evil
villain not me
i think you look like a sexy motorcycle
like that lady gaga album cover finn
charles's mom donated some clothes
i don't know ah
trying not cold it's nice to look like
arsenio so it's
perfect that's actually my wedding suit
no no yes
no but she looks good yeah that's
great perfect you look beautiful
appropriate for court my grandpa was an
old-school cop
this was his hangover cure raw egg yolks
you look like a corpse we just pulled
out of the river wrong i look like a
cool rock star who od'd in his own pool
big difference so i assume you're not
too hungover to do said work
nope it's like i never even drank and
that's not a hangover cure what that
wow it's just some protein for my guns
i drink one every morning before i lift
oh no
oh gross so good
you can barely even tell it's a chicken
embryo you should drink it all
yes you should
that work i have no idea he looks so
abused
i wonder if that was real we're only
tracking people who use the stolen cards
they might not be the same as the ones
who stole them
here switch these with me
oh no oh no someone posted the stolen
card numbers online from this ip address
not bad you found the pattern all right
let's aspirate up and roll out
hello my cal brook nypd open up put your
head through the door
my head
yeah you know i was gonna take him out
myself but
ladies first so relax kid being too
hungover
to chase superb that's a classic
old-school move
he's gotta throw up on it so many good
quotes especially about hope
cops are usually afraid to go after
their captains like that
but you sir are old school oh
no
would you do proto detective diaz would
you please tell the court
exactly how you were involved in this
case i caught mr ladd physically beating
his boss with a fax machine
most of his cheek was caved in his head
was basically a blood fountain
i'm sorry is this amusing to you miss
diaz
[Music]
holt would rather i wear a tie than
solve a case holt cares more about
catching clerical errors than catching
bad guys
he wasn't supposed to quote me i was off
the record the whole time
oh no i'm going on the record
jake peralta can dance
i'll fix it brogan's a cool guy we're
friends now i'll just talk to him
awesome dude
oh geez i think you're nervous of course
i'm nervous
what do you think was a problem we just
assumed you were a terrifying human
being with a short fuse
[Laughter]
you just need to go to your happy place
what's that sounds stupid
well everyone's happy place is different
for me i just imagine i'm slurping up
the world's longest piece of linguine
mmm pesto mmm
carbonara great now i'm starving
oh russian spot for men
so i read those quotes you sent me but i
was pretty drunk when i said that stuff
wait you said you were going on the
record i was clearly not in control
maybe you should learn to handle your
brown ew
i kind of feel like you're being unfair
here feel like listen to her suzanne
summers over here
talk like a man all right i will talk
like a man you got me drunk and took
advantage of me oh come on
i'm asking you nicely please don't print
the quotes and i'm telling you nicely
i'm printing them
no you're not what are you gonna do
about it
hey how'd it go broken perfect except i
punched him in the face and made
everything a billion times worse
what
did he really
no peralta i think i know what happened
no one cares what you think
your client instigated the fight i'm
certain what's her happy place i'm happy
to tell you why
oh she went to her happy place i know
that boyle
what were you thinking i was thinking
that i needed to protect this precinct
every time i think you might make a
decent detective you're gonna pull
something like this i thought i could
handle my brown
[Laughter]
go home you got the rest of the day to
put your head on straight oh
man you assaulted jimmy brogan yeah but
that caveman kind of had it coming don't
you think
uh-oh oh he didn't tell you tell me what
never mind if jake didn't tell you he
must have had a reason it's not my place
i'm disappointed in you santiago i
thought you and i were close
oh no don't fall for it i know you're
manipulating me
but i love it and i will tell you
anything no
[Laughter]
for the record i know that holt is a
stickler but he's actually a really good
cop
don't worry about it we're friends you
don't have to stick up for that homo
oh she just said that
what homo oh
santiago that'll be old dang hell yeah
peralta yeah
that's a cool reveal yes you did it they
found them guilty on all charges
huh wells advice worked
[Laughter]
there's an elbow left in the middle of
nowhere
inside it's just me and that stupid
slimy defense attorney
and i'm beating the hell out of him i
break a dining room table over his head
then i rip off his arm and shove it
where the sun don't shine
then i reach down his throat and shake
his hand
yeah okay i'm gonna go ahead and
schedule you for a psyche valve
i owe you one boyle thank you dinner
tomorrow night
[Music]
yes oh my boyfriend's coming no
the new face of the nypd is perfectly
embodied by brooklyn's own jake peralta
who cowers behind his desk all day like
the true
hair bag that he is there it is the old
guard would have eaten a guy like
peralta for breakfast and
unloaded him by lunch you can ignore
that garbage santiago jimmy brogan
wouldn't know a legit cop he punched him
in the face
yeah oh i was making me miss the outlet
welcome to the party pal
god i love that movie die hard
oh this is the moment what a good show
why can't nbc universal i guess you got
invested with our videos
do you see the joy are you trying to
dismantle this
joy just stop
don't be grinches universes let them go
why the hassle i don't understand
oh that's shitty chatty yeah i was
really touched by that one
yeah that one was that was awesome and
uh
again eight episodes in and they just
keep doing different things right from
the opening of it
with um blowing like the book ends and
blowing something up and then blowing up
um scully that his shoes
yeah yeah scully's shooting yeah yeah
not hitchcock's there's scully yeah
blowing up scully shoes and then even
messing with like the pov you
unfoil like this
that's hilarious that is so funny i love
that cold open
yeah that was a really funny ass one but
then um
this story i thought was so cool like
it's a good
story i thought they told of you know
that phrase of like never meet your
heroes
and it gives you so much insight into
um peralta as well like this guy who
grew up uh like he he
he he quotes die hard again at the end
here
he's obsessed with his book as a kid and
it's just like this
over glamour glamorization of the gritty
badass
loner cop like the how he wants to be
like it just put his character even in
that much more of a clearer
perspective of this guy who wanted to be
an
action hero this i wanted to be the
badass
cop that i i read about and saw movies
on
and then he's like the bits of when he's
meeting his hero
and he's just trying to like embody like
a 70s gritty cop
stupid but he looks like a kid trying to
do it the whole time
yeah that's hilarious ass stuff like
coming up with a different name
and rubbing the ash on him the
cigarettes
and just plain kiss ass and people
pleaser
to it uh that's it's a neat tale
especially because it's
it's it has like the consequences of
meeting your heroes and like
you know the idolization of who you
might have idolized growing up and then
how i mean
in a weird way it's like it's something
that's always been relevant but weirdly
to to do it in today's times i'm like
that was probably even more relevant
when you realize like some people i
really looked up to in the past are kind
of problematic people
you know yeah and then it makes you
wonder like you know how many cops
in our generation have been inspired by
those same kinds of cop movies and books
and stuff like that because it is like a
well-entrenched
part of our culture and whatnot and yeah
i like the way that
even though it does make for a whole ton
of just fun comedy
it also yeah it does feel a bit of a
real learning experience and a real
confrontation of the changing of time
yeah and for a show that i understand
from from what i understand you know at
least does adjust to
uh somewhat the changing climate of
policing
just running alongside the airing of the
episodes like it's cool to see even in
season one them thinking on that level
sort of
yeah of course i mean even going to like
holt's past of
uh i mean even eliminating the whole
fact that he was gay
just being a black cop in the 70s how
there wasn't many black
detectives back then uh it's it's
riffing on something
they make humor out of it but it's done
in a pleasantly
satirical way where you know the show's
not making
uh light of the situation necessarily
you know if anything it's a it's a
comedic way to bring
some awareness to it in a very
heightened nbc show fashion
yeah yeah yeah i really enjoyed this one
like so much yeah and i like the the
storytelling on this one i thought was
probably my favorite so far in terms of
just like just storytelling i don't
often say that with brooklyn nine-nine
using those specific words of he's
slowly just slowly learning and
realizing
that this this man who we put on this
pedestal
is just uh this glamorization is not
what he made him out to be
as it's solely unraveling the quotes
about halt and then having to confront
him and being like
you know you're like the coolest guy
ever but you're i feel like you're being
unfair having that confrontation
and then watching the change of the kind
of person that he really is like he's
not like the cops
from that he probably admired from those
books you know especially with that line
about like
whatever he says about like homos
oh yeah you don't have to stick up for
that whole movie yeah yeah saying that
um and then he punches him and i'm like
damn that is such
like a touching ass moment yeah like the
way how the punch happened
you're like oh peralta you're being
somewhat childish you're hitting him
because he's not removing the quotes
like dude what are you thinking and then
to
and then freaking he doesn't even tell
holt about what happens yeah
and and then holt um you know
uh sends him home but then to have that
like ending moment during
when the credits are playing and he's
he has that like he wouldn't know a
legit cop if you punch him in the face
just like
that's so touching yeah because he
didn't even like
peralta displayed a certain sense of
humility by not
showing am i not telling holt why he
actually punched him yeah you know
yeah and for an episode that has so much
about being on and off the record and
quotes being
or context being misconstrued to have it
come down to
yeah an unspoken truth that then makes
their bond as characters stronger like
yeah
it's surprisingly kind of beautiful what
the format of this
is and it makes all the prior jokes that
much better and even the like goofy
cutaways of hitchcock and uh scully be
like yeah we were a coke in the 70s or
in the 80s or wherever
um yeah it's it's it's like the natural
thing you would want to do in a cop show
like this is
you know do something that harkens to
that era and i thought yeah like you
said it's
it's like a really nice parallel set of
stories and and i liked what they did
with uh
rosa charles and terry too with having
to coach her through
like how to behave on the stand and how
to connect with people
that way and uh even though like you
know the one side of the story has a lot
more of that like cultural relevancy i
thought they made for a nice
two stories to tell side by side in a
way well i don't really watch a lot of
um you know i've seen it in movies and
shows and they're like all right when
you're testifying on the stand let's go
over this let's rehearse this how is it
going to be
but they made something really yes
comedy but they made something
refreshing about um
you know having to train yourself on how
to be on the stand as a cop like i
haven't seen that
yeah yeah i've seen the rehearsal of
what to talk about what to mention what
to say what you're gonna say
uh but they didn't really they didn't go
into that it was just more about how to
how to present yourself as a cop on the
stand yeah
and even even we get nervous and i love
that even that bit of like what did you
guys think
like it's another great character beat
of like what did you think was going on
with me i'm nervous
and they're like oh damn we didn't
realize that and you could totally see
why but also it makes perfect sense that
she might be nervous and yeah just the
the watching her go into her happy place
when it happens was such a wonderfully
played moment like that transformation
in her mood and her
just physical quality at that moment
yeah yeah really nice
and you know what makes it so um
uh like i i know the feeling of being
younger and more like like more mature
in the sense of
when you're when you're talking with
someone you admire you look up to you
become such a yes man
yeah and you just you just feed into
like
whatever you think they're gonna nod
their head at or laugh along with you at
whether that's
something revealing or talking [ __ ] you
know that i i know what it's like to be
that person
and um what what's so gratifying about
the punch moment like i'm so impressed
with that because
i thought it was going to be he insults
amy or says something sexist about her
that's
that's what i thought he it was gonna be
um i didn't realize it
it was uh gonna be that so what makes it
refreshing is that
he he was originally going to him
because he talked so much [ __ ] on holt
as he was drunk
yeah he made all these cracks about him
that were
so insulting and and he wanted to
protect him and and protect the
department
and like oh it really comes across like
he's going after holt and he doesn't
like him
but then the fact that he stood up for
him that he punched his his childhood
hero for insulting him like for
truly insulting him as a person and not
just talking about his behavior
shows that he really likes and cares
about him
all that other stuff that's why i
thought it was so uh that's why i was so
touched
yeah that's why i like kind of moved me
to tears when we were watching it
i was like that's a beautiful yeah i
just
i didn't the last thing i expected was
to get any tad bit emotional over
situations
you know get on the same page together
and every little like
there is something about them it's like
as much as it's fun to watch peralta and
holt be foils for each other and to
aggravate each other
you really good at making you really
want them
to you know have that familial love
i mean for him to say like every time i
think you're this close to being a good
detective like it's
it starts becoming like a cop drama
thing in a way yeah yeah
like everything i think you're this
close oh my god i got all this ink all
over my hands i didn't realize
oh that's what happens when you play
with the ink on a pen
caught you black-handed g uh
yeah we should probably end this video
but yeah scrape that off yeah
what um what uh what we're just talking
about
we're talking about how it's starting to
feel like an actual cop drama
yes because he was saying you just when
i think you're this close to um man you
guys look i don't know because
this was pretty bad uh what would
you to be a decent detective you go and
do something like this
and it's like oh manny he roots for him
but he just
he's disappoint like he's disappointing
him there's like a father-son quality to
their relationship
for sure it's like it literally is like
that i'm not mad i'm disappointed dad
and then he has such a switch and he
realizes why he punched him yeah yeah
and and they don't have to have like
some big conversations just like
good writing just that one one like what
would holt
say in his slick way to let him know
i'm on your side yeah and i understand
yeah
that's so good so touching so yeah i
love this one this is my
this is uh this this went the next step
for me yeah
yeah in terms of like yeah it's not just
a clever comedy anymore about
um it's not just a clever comedy about
you know cops and then being like really
smart and
how they righted and clever you know
like it's all there still during this
one episode but then
to get to the next beat where you can
really have
a like like a strong emotion associated
to it it's always had the harp but to
really
like tug at the feels yeah like damn
that that
that's the next step for me yeah touch
on some emotional truth in the process
yeah it's really is is special yeah it's
special
all right guys leave your thoughts down
below
sorry for whenever this gets temporarily
enjoy it while it's here let's say this
in the video so
you're like yeah oh you're right i guess
here
who's this person manually claiming this
and being like oh [ __ ] you're right yeah
let me unblock this you follow the rules
[Laughter]
i don't know maybe they're just
sticklers for protocol there's like we
have to claim you you have to dispute it
and then we'll be fine yeah so silly
all right guys thank you for being here
talk to you soon